les premiers coups de pelle ont commencé
en septembre 2018 la préparation des
fondations du nouveau gymnase lionel
terray coût global du projet 5 millions
d'euros avec des aides de la région du
département et de saint quentin en
yvelines
on est parti sur un gymnase plus modeste
en terme de taille puisque on sera sur
un seul niveau avec une grande salle
donc omnisports qui fera 1200 mètres
carrés un bâtiment au total qui aura une
capacité d'accueil de nos 1200 m² une
salle multisports et un espace pour les
arts martiaux le nouveau bâtiment sera
accessible au public à mobilité réduite
une reconstruction suivi d'une
démolition de la structure actuelle en
cause la vétusté du gymnase lionel
terray des interventions du service
technique chaque semaine après on voit
plusieurs fissures au niveau 2 du
bâtiment notamment les ferraillage qui
sont maintenant apparent la structure du
bâtiment et plus que vétuste et
aujourd'hui on en arrive jusqu'à
l'intérieur à avoir régulièrement de
l'humidité
on est sur un bâtiment qui est un des
plus vieux de 50 ans nîmes crû de 40 ans
mais qui devient vétuste donc avec de
gros problèmes structurels
nous avions aussi un bâtiment qui est
très énergivore
compte tenu de sa construction mais
aussi compte tenu qu'il est alimenté par
un chauffage est un chauffage commun à
la résidence des nouveaux horizons aux
alentours le collège et le lycée 17 mar
des utilisateurs de ce gymnase au
quotidien tout comme le milieu scolaire
et associatif
ce gymnase et le gymnase le plus utilisé
de la commune du fait de sa position
géographique
il est le plus central pour le coup nous
avons sept groupe scolaire élémentaire
et maternelle qui peuvent s'y rendre à
pied
la finalisation du nouveau gymnase est
prévue pour fin 2010 9
la démolition pourra alors commencer à
la place un parc et des jardins
devraient être créés